let's talk about sarah huckabee sanders
as you know if you've been watching or
listening to the show lately our
president has been on a rampage against
his own FBI currently led by his
selection to be a director of the FBI
chris ray saying that the reputation of
the FBI is in tatters that it's just
terrible James Comey is terrible
Robert molar is terrible he's on a witch
hunt they're dishonest they're phony
it's all horrible back in November of
2016 in fact just a few days before the
presidential election press secretary
will then she wasn't press secretary now
press secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders
tweeted something very interesting she
tweeted something that is now going
viral when she said when you're
attacking FBI agents because you're
under criminal investigation you're
losing I tweeted her and I said hey
Sarah do you stand by this no answer so
far and maybe she'll be asked about it
at today's press briefing and I'm sure
her answer will be something like well
that's because Hillary was engaging in
criminal activity but this is just a
witch-hunt by the FBI of the President
of the United States it's not a double
standard next question or look I find
this question to be disgusting and
offensive that's another one of her
go-to s and for someone who's part of
this anti PC anti outrage culture
brigade it's funny of how frequently
Sarah Huckabee Sanders just finds
questions offensive and this really gets
to my total disgust with Sarah Huckabee
Sanders Sean Spicer the former press
secretary it was stunning how brazenly
Sean Spicer was willing to lie but I had
the sense that like two percent of him
maybe was sort of feeling bad about the
brazen nature of the lies he was hearing
in a certain way wasn't he yeah there
was some element of like man I kind of
feel bad for the guy because yes he's a
fool for agreeing to do this stuff but
something about him made me feel like a
1% ounce of sympathy for him and maybe
that was wrong
I feel none of that for Sarah Huckabee
Sanders I feel absolutely none of it
because she transmits almost like a love
and enjoyment of going out there and
lying she seems to have this visceral
contempt
for the press and so-called educated
liberal elites I get the impression Pat
that she relishes going out there and
just lie lie lie it's a tough job not
many people can do it especially for
this administration yeah she does
decently well I would have to say I mean
given the circumstances right I I mean I
don't know how we even buy whatever six
standards we have to apply to analyze
her job performance you're not wrong
that we could say she kind of does it
well yeah you know it's okay to be
critical of the president every now and
then too I mean I know you're speaking
from his the platform race you're the
word you're the mouthpiece of the
president officially but you you know
you can craft it in a certain way that
it doesn't sound so bad you can do no
wrong I mean there's just no any
question that goes to something that
Trump clearly just messed up on it's an
offensive question it's a bad question
or another clever line from her is I've
already answered that and there's
actually no shortage of sort of these
hilarious old FBI related tweets that
haven't aged well I found one from
Kellyanne Conway she tweeted back in
October of 2016
most honest people I know are not under
FBI investigation let alone - what does
that make her boss Donald Trump then and
I hope that history is accurate with
these people and identifies them as the
charlatans that we know them to be I'm
just surprised that the Ministry of
Truth hasn't wiped this out right yeah
they create their own facts in this
administration they want to replace that
tweet with a documentary about the
bowling-green Massacre which at one
point pulled Kellyanne Conway off a TV
at least